following multiple delays dying light 2
stay human is finally releasing on a
console or pc near you and to prepare
you for all the zombie killing parkour
action that the game has to offer we've
rounded up a bunch of things you need to
know for more dying light videos make
sure you're subscribed to gamespot
dying light 2 stay human is a first
person open world action adventure game
set 20 years after the events of the
first dying light as a brief refresher
for that game there was a deadly virus
that turned those infected into
dangerous zombies it was contained in
the isolated city of haran which
effectively controlled the spread of the
virus for a while until a new strain
escaped the laboratory and eliminated 98
of the world's population modern
civilization as we know it came to an
end pushing humanity into a new dark age
playing as kyle crane an undercover
agent determined to find intel on the
virus you parkour your way around her on
hacking zombies making makeshift weapons
and helping any survivors
in dying light 2 you are no longer kyle
crane instead you play as aidan caldwell
a member of the pilgrims a group of
freelance runners who travel around the
world handling various jobs for people
while risking their lives among the
hordes of infected when we meet aiden he
is headed to the city it does have a
real name it's just more commonly
referred to as the city and he's on a
quest to find his sister mia they were
both a part of mysterious experiments as
children but were tragically separated
during a fire now aiden is haunted by
that past and wants to know exactly what
those scientists were up to as well as
whether or not his sister is still alive
after the global outbreak a few
settlements remained but vilador aka the
city is the largest the city is a
fictional european location based on
turkish and islamic cities that is four
times larger than the world of the
original game within the city you'll be
able to take on side missions explore
abandoned buildings and make essential
choices that will impact the flow of
your story throughout the game aiden
will rub shoulders with various factions
in the city and at critical points in
the plot he'll need to choose whom to
side with those factions include the
survivors who want to establish safe
zones and adapt the renegades
ex-prisoners that want to rule the city
and the peacekeepers loyal soldiers
trying to enforce their version of the
law depending on which factions control
the districts of the city you'll see
changes to the environment that reflect
their ideologies for example choose to
help the survivors and they might build
a school on a rooftop to teach children
however if you choose to help the
peacekeepers instead they'll build an
outpost with a shopkeeper and npcs with
missions for you
similar to the first dying light the
creatures you fight are light sensitive
making it much safer to travel by
daylight than at night however that also
means you're likely to run into nests of
zombies in interior locations making
exploration hazardous stay human also
welcomes multiple new types of special
infected like sleeping beauties
revenants and banshees sleeping beauties
are infected that linger in dark areas
in a drowsy state forcing the player to
sneak around them make too much noise or
shine your flashlight at them for too
long and you risk getting overrun by a
group banshees on the other hand are
quick and often cause me to feel like my
dodging skills need a ton of work but
despite the new monsters to fear and
stay human the volatile is still one
that freaks me out and gets my heart
racing every time it's insanely powerful
and horrifying to look at why couldn't
they have just gone extinct in between
games the dying light series puts a big
emphasis on traversal providing you with
parkour abilities so you can make your
way through its desolate urban landscape
quickly and effectively and stay human
parkour gameplay has been expanded to be
more natural and intuitive to learn some
of these changes include a slow motion
effect and enhanced time in the air
during jumps to compensate for how a
player can't rely on their natural
agility and expanded vision to make
acrobatic decisions on the fly aiden has
athletic conditioning and can maintain a
brisk pace of 14 miles per hour while he
performs various parkour moves
according to the lead game designer
parkour is designed to be both easy to
learn and hard to master and is largely
unaffected by dying light 2's difficulty
modes not including fall damage
modifiers on more challenging settings
there are 24 park horse skills and stay
human for aiden to acquire including
significant jump upgrades wall running
and bashing through enemies without
stopping there are also 24 combat skills
that can be unlocked these include block
charge which as the name suggests
involves you charging at an enemy while
blocking and knocking them to the ground
perfect parry that staggers an enemy
when you block at the last minute and
ground pound a powerful attack while in
midair advanced technology is scarce in
dying light 2 and firearms are hard to
come by requiring you to scavenge parts
and craft makeshift weapons in order to
survive the onslaught of infected along
with enemy factions looking to take what
you have
you'll see some ranged combat as well as
first person melee fighting which will
feel very familiar if you played the
first game in some instances you can
build modded weapons that have multiple
uses along with that modded weapons are
far more effective in the sequel but
your enemies are also far more capable
of taking you down in combat there's
been a lot of hubbub around how long the
game takes to complete according to
teclan a focused playthrough of dying
light 2's main story can be finished in
around 20 hours to complete side quests
learn about the lore and speak with all
the game's characters you'll need about
80 hours and to completely 100 the game
you'll need to devote around 500 hours
of your life adding to this the studio
revealed that the game's script contains
350 000 words amounting to around 40 000
lines of dialogue so essentially if you
stick around for all 500 hours you can
expect to hear all 40 000 lines and if
that isn't enough tecline also said it
is committed to five years of game
support for dying light 2. with this
fans can expect quote more story dlcs
more events more locations and more
in-game items and you don't have to face
the hordes of infected alone dying light
2 will support up to 4 player co-op as
an added twist a party can vote on key
choices that will be made throughout the
campaign although the host of the party
will ultimately have the deciding vote
if you join a friend for a co-op session
all character progress and items earned
will follow you back to your own game
after a co-op session has ended dying
light 2 stay human is set for release on
february 4th 2022 for pc playstation 5
ps4 xbox series xns and xbox one
everyone who buys dying light 2 on ps4
can upgrade to the ps5 edition at no
extra cost additionally dying light 2
supports microsoft's smart delivery
platform which means those who buy the
game on xbox one get it on series x and
s for nothing extra unfortunately
techland announced that cross-platform
and cross-progression co-op play is not
supported at launch on console however
cross play between users on steam and
the epic game store for pc will be
available from day one the game will
also be available on nintendo switch via
cloud streaming however nintendo players
will have to wait a little longer for
that version as it was delayed on
january 19th and is now slated to arrive
sometime within six months of february
4th and there you have it everything you
need to know before becoming aiden and
fighting to stay human dying light 2 has
a ton to do and seems to be a great
world to get lost in if having the
constant threat of being eaten is your
kind of thing so hit the like button if
you've enjoyed this video and then head
over to the comment section and let us
know if you're excited for dying light
2. do you plan on playing it for 500
hours or will another one of february's
big releases pull you away thanks for
watching